I'm Jim Chris I work for continuum
analytics we're the makers of anaconda
and I'm here to talk to you about desk
so first we'll start with what is desk
how many people here have heard of desk
before oh wow this is way up from last
year awesome
how many people have used desk okay
fewer how many hope to use desk yay okay
so in brief for people that are not
aware desk is a parallel computing
framework it's a very general system we
can you can take a rhythms of many
different types it doesn't need to be
just MapReduce it's written in pure
Python so it's really easy to install
you can just pip install it kind of
install it everything works there's no
compiled dependencies it leverages the
excellent Python ecosystem we try to
build off tools that already exist so we
build off pandas we build off a numpy
those are great libraries we try to make
them just work better and a parallel and
distributed context and it uses blocked
algorithms and task scheduling so what
is the blocked algorithm a blocked
algorithm is a way to take some large
tasks and split into many small tasks
that can then be done hopefully in
parallel so here's an example of a
blocked mean say we have some trillion
element array on disk and in fact won't
take the mean we don't want to load the
entire trillion elements in the memory
at once that's a lot so instead we'll
split it into 1 million chunks and then
for every chunk we will pull out the
chunk will summit and store the sum away
we'll count how many elements are in it
and we'll store those away and at the
very end we'll sum the sums and we'll
sum the counts and then we'll divide the
sums by the counts to get the mean and
so if we were to draw this out as a
directed acyclic graph it might look
like this so we have a bunch of little
map steps that are doing the sums and
the counts and at the very end we pulled
them all together and get the mean and
so looking at that loop none of the
steps you know step one step two step
three depend on any previous or needs
subsequent step so it can all be done in
parallel
so normal up most the time you don't
need to worry about any of this a desk
has lots of collections like desk or a
looks like an umpire a desk data frame
looks like pandas you don't really need
to be writing these algorithms yourself
and you don't really need to be
concerned about what the graphs look
like so here's an example of a new desk
library called desk search TV mirrors
scikit-learn x' grid search TV which is
just a drop-in replacement you write
code that looks like normal scikit-learn
code builds a graph find the scenes that
you never really need to see and then
the schedulers run it and so all this
kind of can happen automatically and you
don't need to care this talk is about
what happens when things don't work
right when you find bugs when you find
performance problems things that you
might expect to be faster but aren't so
in the talk about debugging I'm going to
do this thing that everyone says you
shouldn't do and I'm going to be live
coding and hopefully that all works can
everyone see that is that a big enough
font cool so a little bit small cool
better
Lebar cool okay so I'm going to working
through one long example with San
dataset whole way through so right here
we have some flight data this is taken
all the flights in and out of New York
from 1990 through 1999 start up terminal
so just looking at the first little bit
here
you can see we have some time so the
year month day of the month departure
time arrival time pollen trip was
delayed if it was canceled the origin so
the originating airport so all these are
flights out of New York and so we're
going to be doing one task and the task
we want to do is we want to take all of
the different files and we want to be
computing the resampled value comes to
the origin so basically we want to get
for every month from 1990 through 1999
we want to get how many flights were out
of each airport and we also want to do
that by year so 1990 91 92 so a way to
do that
serially using pandas we might loop over
all the data read it in we're going to
parse the first three columns which were
as a date separately and we're going to
tell pandas to infer the day time format
for those that don't know about this
keyword aren't familiar with pandas this
allows pandas to be slightly faster for
reading date times we're going to then
store the data frames together in a big
list and at the very end word to
concatenate them together and then it's
one call to do resample giving V value
counts by origin and another one to do
it by year
so running that it's going to take a
little bit time this is all being done
serially using pandas should take around
Aereo and taking a look at the results
we can see that we have yes one per
month counts out and for year one per
year and we can even plot this using
bouquet so you can see that there's way
for your flights out of JFK so this took
a little bit too much time so we'd like
to paralyze it and since it's a stock
we're going to try to paralyze it using
desk so one of the tools we have to
paralyze things in desk is something
called delayed delayed is a fairly
simple function it does two things if
you call delayed on a function it makes
it delayed it will run later and if you
call delayed on some data
it makes using that data lazy so if you
call methods on it or use operators on
it it'll be lazy so a simple first
application this might look like this so
we are calling delayed on read CSV and
then we're calling delayed on
concatenate so we're going to be reading
from disk lazily and we're going to be
concatenated the resulting lazy data
frames together lazily the rest of these
method accesses operators are all lazy
by default things that touch delayed
objects become lazy too so if I pull it
in
and if we time that ran really fast and
that's because haven't done anything yet
behind the scenes Daffy has just built
up graphs and we can take a look at them
using the visualized method to zoom in a
little bit so you can see now at the
bottom here we have all our calls to
read CSV and then they merge together
and then we have a big serial operation
given the actual accounting since we
have two results rows one which is by
month and two which is by year we don't
want to call compute on them
individually if we call Camille and
individually each time we call compute
it's going to do all of those tasks it's
going to read in the CSV is it's going
to merge them all together and it's
going to do the value comes operation we
want and so if we call compute twice
we're going to do the reading from disk
twice which is going to be slower so
instead we can use something called def
compute this is the same as the dot
compute method but it will merge the
graphs together and you can look at what
the merge graphs looks like we had a
visualize so you can see they both share
the same reading from disk and
concatenate operation but then they have
two different chains for resampling by a
year and resampling by month
so let's time how long that actually
takes to compute
so that was about nine seconds which is
faster than our original initial one
which was about thirteen but it still
isn't great also there's some issues
here with this oh you make these so
going back to our graph that we had
does anyone see an issue with this so we
end up reading all of data in from disk
at once and making one big data frame
we're not doing any of this lazily this
is the same as if we were to do this
with pandas and we could actually
measure our memory usage using memory
profiler which is a has an iPad on magic
Amendment
Oh
there we are
so we can actually member measure our
memory usage as this runs through with
the memory profiler this is a useful
tool for just measuring normal Python
code this is going to measure the peak
usage which was about three gigs and
it's going to measure the change so if
one when it started to when it ended
which was about a gig and if you
actually we're to look at the files you
can see that that was the entire file
right there we read in all ten files
have that in memory at once and then
ended up with a whole data frame in
memory we don't actually need to do that
if we rethink our algorithm so here is a
third version so instead of reading
everything in memory concatenated it
together and then using it as one giant
pandas dataframe we can rethink how
we're computing this we can still load
in the file
oh I've rewritten these to use functions
and you can use delayed from task is to
decorate around the function which makes
the function lazy so we have a function
called load file which reads in from
disk this is the same pandas call we had
before we have a function called count
flights is going to take in a single
data frame it's going to resample it by
month each file is broken in by year so
there's going to be twelve rows from the
results of this and then count the
values on the origin we're they going to
take all of the counts so one Kyle to
count flights per file and we're going
to merge them together by concatenate
them that's going to get our resampled
counts per month and then we're going to
do the count by year by just summing
those so this is Mac it's going to be
slightly different
it's going to be different than the last
one in that we're not going to have to
have all of the data in memory at once
so looking at the graphs you can see now
that we load the file and then we
immediately reduce it with count flights
to something much smaller and then we
merge them together and calling compute
on that with the memory profiler again
should take just a couple seconds we can
see that our change was very small so we
ended up with only loading one or two
the files into memory at once that's
custom earn enough to walk through the
graph and compute the reduced version of
the file and then remove that from
memory before it moves on and so this
shows how to ask if you had say you know
much larger files or many many more
files you can work with larger datasets
without having to have them all in
memory but still getting parallelism
alright so this is still slightly slower
than we want so another useful tool in
the Python ecosystem is something called
snake this have anyone used snake this
before cool I get to show you something
awesome so I did not like this I have
not worked on this but this tool is
amazing so it's a profiler for Python
code also has on my Python magic called
snake Asst we're going to call it on our
computer eight here one other thing
we're going to do is we're going to
specify which scheduler to use so snake
this works with regular Python code but
when profiling bass code you want to use
the serial scheduler so far we've been
using the threaded scheduler which is
running everything in parallel using
threads profiling with the threaded
scheduler with snake this kind of gets
weird so I run this this should take
around ten seconds if I remember
correctly and what this is doing is this
is using the normal Python profiler and
then snake va's makes a really nice
visualization that you can walk through
and see yep let's increase the depth
cool so this fancy lookin plot at the
very center here is the top level it's
what you called your function with and
then you walk out you're walking into
the lower and lower low levels in the
sec so the first couple things here are
all inside the desk scheduler but
eventually we get out to some tasks so
right here we can see this is the load
file tasks that we wrote and you can see
that most of our time about 10 seconds
worth of it is reading from disk so the
actual computation is a lot smaller than
just read from disk
so this is something we can fix by
switching how we're using pandas so here
the only change between version 3 and
version 4 is we're going to use pandas a
lot smarter so we're going to use the
used calls keyword for those not
familiar with this this says Japan does
that it only needs to read in these four
columns because these are the only
columns we care about just the ones that
are the time so year-month-day a month
and in the originating airport we're
also going to specify the D type of the
origin as a category categorical D types
allow pandas to be more memory efficient
and also work a lot faster because it
can work with things that can numeric
key types underneath everything else is
the same
the rest of this is exactly the same as
the previous version so let me quick
import it and then we'll call em it
time that what we're doing Oh No
there's an error so something didn't
work right how can we debug this so one
really nice thing about the ask is
because it's a pure Python and because
it's pure Python it works well with the
normal ways you divide Python so we can
actually use PDV so I'm going to turn
PDB on and then I'm going to call
compute again by show of hands how many
people have used PDB at least once
before cool about half the room so PDV
is the Python debugger right now we are
in the stack of where it aired before
this part it was all running parallel on
threads at this point the scheduler is
completely stopped and we're just
looking at a single task and so we see
the type error datatype not understood
this is somewhere inside pandas the d
type variable looks interesting let's
see what that is and through that type
of that is what I meant to be a
dictionary is actually a set I mistyped
a colon as a comma so step out of that
version 5 has that fixed this used to be
a comma now it's a colon so that shows
that when you want to debug desk issues
you can just use normal Python tools and
everything works that does not work with
a distributed scheduler or the multi
processing scheduler but it does work
well with things that run in the same
process which is the recommended way to
debug so going back to that
let's run version 5 of this and commit
just realize I haven't explained this
the percent time method in ipython if
you're not familiar with it is a way to
time single lines or multiple lines
which is really good for profiling and
since this is just Python that works
well so that took about four seconds
which is a big improvement but it still
isn't great so so far we've been
parallel or profiling using normal
Python tools snake phase memory profiler
just using the time magic in ipython now
we're going to move on to some very desk
specific things so desk has a
Diagnostics module now at Diagnostics
which has a couple tools in it that are
useful for memory or measuring
performance and desk so here I'm going
to import profiler resource profiler and
a visualized function so profiler
measures tasks probe these confuses
context managers profiler measures the
performance of a single task you get a
nice plot that shows tasks over time
resource profiler measures CPU usage I'm
going to tell it to measure your CPU and
memory usage every tenth of a second and
everything inside this with block is
then going to be profiled and we will
call compute on our task objects and let
that run should take about four seconds
and then visualize you pass on a list of
profiling objects and we get a nice
fancy bouquet plot
cool is that big enough so the top plot
here is our task plot each of these
rectangles represents a task the x-axis
is time so here this is the load file
task which is reading from disk with
pandas this right here is the counting
flights so you can still see that
loading from disk load file is taking
most of the time the bottom one down
here is CPU and memory usage the blue
line is very and the purple is CPU so I
have in my computer for actual cores
eight virtual of course I would expect
around 4x speed up I'd like spec to be
using about four hundred percent CPU
here we're getting a parallelism and
then suddenly it drops down to just a
100% and this isn't a thread pool does
anyone know why I'm not actually getting
parallelism here even though it looks
like we have eight taps running at once
exactly yeah the global interpreter lock
so python has a global interpreter lock
which means that normal Python code can
only be running in one thread at a time
certain libraries like numpy and pandas
can release the gill during numeric
operations but not all of them and so
here we can see that the call to read
CSV doesn't paralyze it it holds on to
the interpreter lock which means that
even though we have eight tasks that are
seemingly running at once it's really
only doing one thing at a time
except for this first little bit which
is actually just loading the bytes and
then later on we see a nice spike in
performance and you can actually see
count flights running here value counts
is the paralyzer below in pandas it
removes the go so what can we do well
one thing we can do is we can swap out
the scheduler so desk decouples
specifying algorithms as graphs and
where you run them with a scheduler so
so far we've been using the threaded
scheduler and then when we were using
snake has earlier we used the serial
scheduler the one that runs just in the
main thread there's another scheduler
the multi processing scheduler i'm vera
desktop multi processing and so running
with profiling again
you can specify what Schedule D is using
the get keyword has to compute so here
I'll specify to use the multi processing
scheduler and we'll run our profiling
again Andry plot it and that took a lot
less time let's do that one more time
we got weird things with the resource
profiler there we go so I talked about
just under two seconds and you can see
here we have all the load file tasks
running and we're getting about eight
hundred percent CPU I'm using all of my
cores I'm actually getting parallelism
here where I wasn't before and that was
just by swapping out the scheduler one
interesting thing here you can see
before we had a task for loading and we
had a task for counting the multi
processing scheduler has rewritten the
graph to merge those two together they
were linear chains of tasks and so
they've been merged together into one
task if you can read that I don't know
if you can the task on that tooltip
there says count flights wrapped around
load file so those are both being called
in the same operation that's really nice
for multi processing because then they
can all be see realized once back from
the process or from the worker to the
main process
let's see cool we can also run this
distributed Vasquez distributed
scheduler in general we recommend using
the distributed scheduler over the
multi-processing scheduler for reasons
I'll get into so the distributed
scheduler can be started by importing
from desk distributed import a client to
start a local scheduler you can just
create an instance of clients and this
is going to spin up a couple processes
locally by default it will have one
process per core so I should have eight
workers and you can see on the wrapper
there I have a processes
on eight-course when you create a client
it automatically takes over as the
default global scheduler so just calling
compute again should use distributed one
nice thing about the distributed
scheduler is it has its own built-in
Diagnostics so the desk Diagnostics
module doesn't work with the dish rooted
scheduler it works with the threaded
multi processing and serial scheduler
but not distributed so here is the
dashboard for the distributed scheduler
calling compute again should kick that
off and we can see the same kind of task
plots we were looking at before but
these update in real time as the
scheduler is running so here's their
call to load file counting from flights
let's kick that up to run a bit more I'm
going to use desk array to build a
larger computation so creating a random
array I don't know 10,000 by 10,000
broken into chunks of two thousand by
two thousand and I some I will say
matrix multiplied with its transpose and
take the sum I don't know cool
so that's kicking off here and you can
see the taps grunting alone down below
we have the progress bar so these are
all the different tasks in the graph
that this is composed of updating in
real time up top we have a bar for every
worker showing the memory usage as the
workers get more saturated so they've
divided up my memory here if they're
using more than they should be or
getting close to it they turn red or
orange and then red over here you can
see the different tasks processing for
each worker how many they have when the
bar turns red here it shows tasks that
are being stolen from one worker to
another
that worker we had too many things
allocated and so they were moved to a
different worker in general the
a certain scheduler has a lot fancy
heuristics about where to run things
that tries to move computations to where
the data is rather than moving the date
of the computations it's a lot easier to
serialize a function that is to
serialize a large array so this is all
running locally on my computer it takes
it works fairly well but we can also
scale out so I've started up a
distributed scheduler on ec2 using the
desk et2
command-line tool it's just a one-liner
to send something up you specify your
credentials what kind of machines you
want to use you can add tags so I have
tagged billing group and stuff and I'm
going to run the same thing on that one
so create disputed schedule you need to
pass in the address of it so I'm stored
that here this is the address to
register to scheduler and so you can see
this one has seven workers each with 20
with 28 course total so there's 8
threads on each one for 4 threads this
is again set itself up as the default
scheduler trying to compute the same
tasks as before it's going to spin this
up here you can see them all working
here in real-time view little bits of
red you're seeing overlaying there are
serialization that's sending some
intermediate result to a different one
in general red is bad but if it's small
it doesn't really matter and that took a
lot shorter time than it did to run
locally so that's can help you scale out
sometimes if you want to improve
performance and you have already thought
about a better algorithm already improve
the performance of your individual tasks
scaling out to multiple machines can
help things run faster last example here
so using the same air airline data set
we used before this is all stored on s3
start on s3 we have a data frame or I'll
just actually write this year using
adapts data frame which is another
collection that mirrors pandas so using
a same read CSV calls you would for
pandas but I can pass in an s3 URL to
bloat from s3
this is going to be set up on the
judiciary the scheduler and then I'm
going to call something called persist
and what persist does is persistent
slight compute but instead of computing
it says compute and then leave
everything on the workers so this is
going to persist it in memory we're
going to load all the data from s3 and
then keep it in memory which is going to
be a lot more performant than reading it
from s3 every time you want to compute
before when you're written locally we
were reading from disk every call now
everything is stored in memory on this
cluster and so I can do things like
group by origin take the departure delay
and figure out what the mean of it is
and let's say the top five and that
returns almost instantly and this is a
large data set stored distributed across
the cluster and if you wanted to watch
at see if we
you can see that update here and to all
the little task bars for the different
operations succeed in conclusion
so in summary think about your problem
there may be a better algorithm we
started off with something that was
parallel but wasn't thinking properly
about how we could improve parallelism
and reduce memory usage we wanted to
load the data and then dump it quickly
by making our intermediates a lot
smaller
you want to maximize parallelism usually
and you want to minimize the
intermediate data size we don't wanna be
keeping lots of things in memory we
don't want to be sending large objects
between workers think about when to call
compute if we call in one of the earlier
examples that we called compute on both
intermediate separately we'd be reading
from disk twice rather than once you can
use desk compute to compute multiple
task objects at the same time in one
single pass rather than having multiple
passes through you can use desk
visualize to look at the graphs I didn't
actually mention that last one I'll skip
that profile profiling is really good
don't guess where the bottlenecks are
measure where they are snake fizz and
line profiling which is another great
tool for measuring performance of single
lines in Python are both good for
measuring the performance of tasks so
little functions that are in your graphs
the desk diagnostics and a distributed
dashboard are useful for measuring the
performance of parallel computations
debug locally desk is easiest to debug
in a single machine so running locally
in a thread pool or in a single thread
PDB works fine with that so your normal
debugging tools are helpful error
messages are your friends reading what
they report we for our data collections
we try to provide useful error messages
and things go wrong under shared context
scale-out if needed if your problem is
big enough and you've tried to improve
performance locally sometimes scaling
out to distribute cluster can be helpful
more machines more cores you can do more
things at once you can use persist to
store things in memory I get just as
with compute you want to think about
when you want to call that sometimes
doing some filtering setting in index
and then calling persist can keep a
smaller set of data
memory than you would have initially the
distributed Diagnostics page is super
helpful acknowledgments task is open
source we have a large development team
across the world
you know people both working for
continuum and external Syfy developer
community people who are kinda number 5
pandas everything I've been super useful
for feedback and providing amazing
libraries that we can build off of my
work continuum is sponsored by the Gorn
and Metis Betty Moore Foundation and the
DARPA X data program unlike an
employer's continuum analytics questions
I get Jim questions in the back
so the question is when would you use
multiprocessing versus distributed so
the reason you'd use distributed over
multi-processing is the multi processing
scheduler it has some flaws in it that
are not fixable with the way it's
written so it's it builds off the same
infrastructure the threaded scheduler
does and that means that all
intermediates are brought back to the
main process before being sent out again
we don't leave data on the workers for
multi processing the distributed
scheduler can be a lot smarter about
things and that's can be a lot more
efficient the developer community of
desk sees the multi processing scheduler
is only useful for small Map Reduce like
tasks or tasks where your intermediates
are very small so things that aren't
data frames things that might just be
you know Python integers or small lists
so for example another collection I
didn't mention was desk bag gasbag works
great with the multi processing
scheduler because of the graphs that
kind of produces the multi processing
scheduler does not play as well with
data frame any other questions
there's someone up front here yeah
so you mentioned that there's quite a
few things you're taught that don't work
is there a summary of those private
allowance things that don't work so that
is in the documentation there's there's
a whole page on what to do use when to
use each scheduler and that's that's I I
think fairly well highlighted there the
I think the other thing I probably
mentioned was that the Diagnostics desk
Diagnostics are only made to work with
the local schedulers and I think that's
also in the docs on the Diagnostics page
so anyone else
okay let's thank the speaker
[Applause]